a hasty exit in houston
chinese officials were seen packing on
friday
they were forced to evacuate the
consulate within 72 hours
a deadline set by the trump
administration
hauling documents into vehicles the exit
was welcomed by anti-communist
party protesters
the u.s says the consulate was a nest of
spies
trying to steal intellectual property
including data from medical facilities
in texas
after the last diplomats departed the
area was cordoned off and u.s
officials were seen forcing entry into
the building
in a tit-for-tat move china has ordered
the closure of the u.s consulate
in the southwestern city of chengdu
china's foreign ministry called the
retaliation legitimate and necessary
accusing u.s staffers of interfering in
the country's internal affairs
the current situation in china u.s
relations is not what china wants and
the us is completely responsible for all
of this
the cold war era style tension between
the two countries has been rising for
some time
often sparring over trade technology and
more recently the coronavirus
usually very outspoken on china the u.s
president has yet to comment on this
latest escalation
joining us now is tyson barker he's a
researcher from the truman
national security project here in berlin
i'm going to start with the first
obvious question tyson barker tensions
between
the u.s and china over spying
accusations
aren't new so why the closure of
houston's consulate now
well it's a great question i think there
are a couple of reasons some are
diplomatic some are political
we did hear from the department of
justice the
unsealing of indictments related to
chinese hackers who were
aggressively uh probing
research into vaccines for covet 19.
this has been pretty systemic
so that is kind of belongs to that
narrative clearly we have an escalation
in in hong kong and xinjiang as well but
the big
reason we have to say or one of the big
reasons has to be political
um the trump administration is trying to
draw a
bright line between its um approach to
china and the biden administration of
potential biden administration's
approach to china saying that
uh biden would be uh less more
conciliatory more accommodation as to
chinese authoritarianism secretary of
state mike pompeo called for
a joint reaction to act over what he
calls
the threat of a new tyranny from china
does he expect support from the european
union
i well clearly he expects support from
the european union and it's one of the
reasons he
made this uh trip uh through europe uh
this week he was very much trying to
uh you know close ranks within the
alliance the transatlantic alliance he
visited denmark
he visited a great britain of course not
a member of the european union anymore
but
basically saying you know we need to
approach this as a united front
so yes that's the expectation what have
been the reactions here in the eu
well the eu uh has the reaction has been
mixed and
the truth is that there are a plurality
of views uh you have countries that are
more hawkish like sweden
you have a country like the uk that has
really evolved i would say
in the past six months from a position
that was much more accommodationist too
much more hawkish
and then you have countries like uh
germany and france which really have
a broad span of equities uh related to
china
first and foremost the trade
relationship which has really taken a
hit because of kovid
that they really want to maintain so
they are much more
stability-minded i would say um the
european commission itself brussels
itself has
issued a strategy last year report last
year which said that china is a
strategic rival of the european union so
there is movement to see
uh china with a more uh more skepticism
than in the past but that is not a
consensus view within europe
i think it's safe to say watch this
space particularly with the united
states entering its
political season tyson barker thank you
so much for that
thank you
you